you
[Music]
this is a presentation I've been working
on for a couple weeks now I've been
delivering it a few times at meetups and
other conferences it's called fast data
apps with help packet capture connector
and akka streams so we're going to talk
about two things we're going to talk
about what alpaca Kafka is and and akka
streams and we're going to dive into a
specific implementation within alpaca
Kafka since I have limited time I chose
transactions for for transactional work
flows with katka so I figured that might
be interesting so my name is Shallon
glover I'm a principal engineer at light
Bend I'm a member of the fast eater
platform team and faccio platform is a
commercial product that like Bend
provides is sort of like cloud era or
Hortonworks it's a distribution of
stream processors as well as support for
underlying infrastructure we started
with DC West Apache mezzos but we've
recently moved to kubernetes and
OpenShift and we support Kafka under for
all of these stream processors as well
and and that's what I specialize in on
the team so I because of that I've
contributed to the Kafka ecosystem
including Kafka itself I helped develop
the Scala DSL for cactus dreams I I
worked on alpaca Kafka itself it used to
be called reactive katka it's been
around for maybe five years so you might
have heard of it by that name Stream Z
is a really neat project I encourage
people to check out if they want to run
kapha on kubernetes it's it's pretty
mature they just released their first
production ready version and if you use
kubernetes you would you'll definitely
find that project interesting and then
the DCOs commons sdk is a library to
help write stateful services to run on
DCOs and apache mezzo so I was involved
in that
last year so alpaca alpaca is a open
source initiative to integrate disparate
systems together so it's a container
project that it's basically a container
project project around all these
different connectors to various systems
it doesn't have any source code itself
it just has documentation they might
have source code in the future but it's
a very developer centric set of modules
to use to connect these systems together
using a cast reims
and we're going to talk about what
active streams is and why you should
care about it
but it is very similar to other projects
out there use for ETL operations like
apache camel calf could connect unlike
connect that it's not declarative it's a
it's a look they're just the modules or
libraries you bring in just like any
other library dependency and it helps it
helps people build these reactive
integration pipelines using a principle
known as back pressure which is a one of
the key attributes of a katrin's and you
can write these apps in Java and Scala
so here's a kind of logo cloud of the
different connectors that are available
I put them into groups there's
connectors for cloud services so AWS s3
sqs dynamodb pub/sub for Google Cloud
and data stores pretty much all the big
ones you can think of like Cassandra
HDFS [ __ ] solar and then of course
messaging we support implementations
AMQP implementations like rabbitmq JMS
and of course Kafka itself so the alpaca
Kafka connector is the connector the
connect cockpit active streams and it
was formerly known as a kiss Reims
catkin before that reacted Kafka it
actually predates the alpaca an issue
which started a couple years ago it was
created by a company called south where
a mill about five years ago I think and
eventually brought in as an official
active project so I worked I worked for
light Bend which which stewards the
active project they so they brought it
into the under the act that github
organization and as a result a lot of
the active committers you know made look
made a lot better it's used by a lot of
our our clients our commercial clients
but it's it's probably one of the most
popular if not the most popular client
library for people who are in this gal
ecosystem developing scale apps to
connect to Kafka and it's it's used in
some of our other open source projects
too so the ground legume is a micro
service framework it's used for as one
of the options for message passing
between micro services and it's used in
a new commercial product we're shipping
early next year called fast to the
pipelines as the basically the glue
between your components and your
pipelines it's the because it's been
around for so long it's the top down
loaded module for all packet capture
these are just stats for August 28 2018
I don't have updated ones but so akka
streams let's talk about what makes
active streams unique so it's a it's a
toolkit to provide low latency complex
event processing streaming semantics
using something called the reactive
screams specification and it's
implemented internally using akka actors
so like the old actors the actresses you
might have heard of akka is the JB is a
JVM based implementation of allowing you
to build actor systems it was originally
created to simplify streaming semantics
within actor systems so if you're
familiar with those
you'll know that there are most the most
basic parts of them are akka actors and
then they communicate with one another
a synchronously by passing messages back
and forth so you can ah that's a pretty
low level communication model and you
can do any kind of streaming semantics
you want with that but it's fairly
difficult to model more kind of
high-level abstract semantics so active
streams was the reason the reason it was
created was to make those streaming
semantics easier in various parts of
ACTA for for the types of systems that
you're building so it reduces a lot of
boilerplate and and makes it easier to
build these types of systems with with
less experience it's built it runs it's
built in in akka
after system itself but it's that's not
exposed to the end user and the user can
pick up this library bring it into any
JVM project Java project and start using
it they don't have to know what actors
aren't but we'll talk a bit more about
actors and how IFAs streams is designed
in the next slide here so the most basic
active stream is a source and a sink
source has at least one outlet a sink
has at least one Inlet and then you have
this arbitrary number of flows in
between that's doing some sort of
processing on your data and the the big
the big difference between active
streams and other stream processors like
spark or flank or kapha streams is that
they they support this back pressure
protocol here and so there's two there's
two communication channels there's two
flows happening within an active stream
there's obviously the the user-defined
messages or are flowing downstream but
there's also an upstream channel that's
used for this back pressure protocol and
we'll explore a bit
about why you want back pressure but in
in a nutshell it's basically to
accommodate the fast producer slow
consumer problem or you don't want a
fast producer overwhelming any of your
systems downstream so that this allows
you to signal upstream hey can you
please slow down so you don't overwhelm
me and make me crash because a lot of
systems don't have the well whatever the
weakest point in your system your
internal infrastructure might be is
probably the first one to fail and
oftentimes there might not be a backup
and you'll get some cascading failure
across your infrastructure so back
pressure is really good too
is a really good way to handle scale
like that if it works for your
requirements so the reactive stream
specification is an initiative to
provide async for the stream processing
with non blocking back pressure so
action streams is basically an
implementation of this it borrows a lot
of the same principles from the reactive
manifesto which is a set of principles
to to build to help build flexible
loosely coupled scalable systems that
communicate with asynchronous messaging
so this spec was spearheaded by light
Bend but it has a lot of contributions
from big stream big companies in the
streaming space like Netflix and and Red
Hat and pivotal and and others as well
so act like I said ice-creams is one
implementation there's several JVM
implementations out there these are just
a few there's implementations and other
language runtimes to has not specific to
the JVM and it was also proposed to be
included in in the JDK and it was
accepted not too long ago so as of JDK 9
there is a set of types under this
package that is semantically equivalent
one to one semantically equivalent with
how with all of the
terms defined in the react respect so
what we're going to see is over time
once the community moves past Java 8
we'll probably will probably see most
people picking up JDK 11 once mostly
community has moved there a lot of these
libraries are going to start having
releases that use this implementation
instead of their own internal
implementations so this is a little demo
on how backpressure works so each each
source flow or sync here is represented
by an actor behind the scenes and there
there's several important traits of in
that actor one is that each each actor
has this little mailbox and this mailbox
is basically the where the message is
kind of buffer before they actually
enter an actor to be processed each each
one of these components they're called
graph stages I'll start using that term
from now on each one of these graph
stages like an actor only processes one
message at a time and that's what makes
it easy in in actor systems to model
concurrency you don't have to worry
about you know another another thread
closing over the same state that your
path of execution might be currently on
afternoons give you that that isolation
and if you want to model concurrency you
used to have more act akka actors and
they'll have their own mail boxes and
then they can concurrently do things but
by having by having them by by
processing one message at a time you get
a lot of flexibility in defining state
and that's the third thing each one of
these graph stages can encapsulate state
within them okay so to begin the demo
when you start your active stream
there's nothing happening there's no
messages flowing until the sink realizes
that it has no messages to process and
there's no downstream s graph stage it
says it's the end of line so it it sends
a demand request upstream so that this
uses that back pressure channel I I
showed an earlier slide it sends this
demand request upstream it propagates to
the flow the flow doesn't have any
messages to give it so it it moves up to
the source and then the source does what
the source does and loads messages in
this in this case it's loading from a
casket topic but you could use another
alpaca connector here and load it from
whatever once the once the source has
some messages available it knows that
the flow is waiting for messages so it
sends messages to the flow and then the
flow is processing messages and it
satisfies the demand request from the
sink and sends messages to it so the way
to get into a little more detail on how
this works you can imagine if so so a
lot of people call the this this kind of
process of streaming the pole model
where downstream things are pulling
messages upstream and it can be
inherently slow in a naive
implementation so if you have you can
imagine one request one demand requests
per message then obviously with millions
of messages you're going to get a lot of
chatter on that communication channel so
the way around that is to is to request
more than one message so how do we how
do we figure out how many messages we
can accommodate so that's where these
mailboxes come into play so in a normal
actor system you have mailboxes and if
you don't specify a different one it's
the default one is unbounded so it can
grow
infinitely large and you can imagine in
certain scenarios that it could grow so
large that it would basically run out of
memory so by default NAFTA streams the
mailboxes for each graft stage are
bounded so it knows exactly how many
messages it can buffer and that's what
it sends when it sends this to manage
requests and says I can handle exactly
this many messages in my mailbox in
practice you probably have a lot more
than that and it sends that along with
the demand requests upstream and it's
basically the pull side of this dynamic
push-pull that that were we're going
over right now and then the the source
can then push messages downstream so it
doesn't need to wait for one demand per
message it knows it can send a batch
which is basically what per semantics
are doing they're just batch sending
things as fast as possible and if
there's no back pressure then then you
can get into trouble with that model but
because it knows it can handle up to
five messages that's what it sends so
this is a this is the example of the
fast producer slow consumer problem
where and and this is how we handle it
in extremes so once this mailbox is full
there's no more demand requests coming
from the flow so this this situation
should never happen the message
shouldn't be sent but if it did they
would be dropped because it can't be
accommodated in this in this mailbox so
Kefka show of hands who kind of knows
what Kafka is okay good I'll have to
talk about it much so there's there's
the quote you know a big distributed
streaming system fast high-volume fault
tolerant all those great things it's a
relatively simple architecture and
it it offloads a lot of complexity to
clients so alpaca Catholic connector is
this is an example of you know one of
those clients modeling some more complex
behavior over top of calf cover for
interesting message delivery semantics
Kafka is really good at absorbing high
load so it's sort of counter to what
active streams is all about akka streams
is about a calming just enough data you
can tune the mailboxes and whatever to
to accommodate more messages you can
scale them out horizontally and
accommodate more load that way but Kafka
doesn't have any means of back pressure
it just it's designed to accommodate as
much low as possible it's like the shock
absorber for your internal
infrastructure you can put it on the
periphery except like high bursts spike
spikes of traffic and then your
consumers can catch up at their own
speed but act but akka streams when it
connects when it loads data from calf
'get can't propagate back pressure
messages over through Kafka unless you
modeled that but I would argue that that
that doesn't make sense because that's
not a catfish strong suit is anyway so
usually an alpaca Kafka pipeline or a
pipeline using active streams is is
starting with Kafka and then there are
other components that you're
communicating with over three different
means so not through Kafka topics but
maybe through just a TCP socket or a gr
PC connection and those those means of
communicating we can support back
pressure through so back pressure isn't
just exhibited through you know a single
application you have running on one node
it can be it can span multiple network
hops as long as those network hops
support some means of back pressure so I
early gave a few examples examples er PC
and and just plain old TCP sockets so
what when would you use alpaca kappa /
kappa streams so they're very similar
they're both live just libraries so
unlike spark or flank which are
frameworks and require a cluster
resource manager and place to do any you
know large workloads alpaca Khafre and
CAFTA streams are just library
dependencies you bring into a JVM app
and then it's up to you to figure out
how to deploy that scale it if you need
to but one obviously back pressure is
one unique feature that a lot of these
other stream processors don't have so if
that's interesting to you then this this
is probably a good technology that
consider complex event processing so in
most cases if you want to do any kind of
CEP you're calling out to other other
systems which can be a very brittle
activity but with ACTA streams as you
might imagine it has very good
integration with akka actor systems and
actor systems are a great way to model
very complex business requirements you
can have actor systems that are a single
JVM maybe they're running in the same
JVM as the stream itself or you can have
cluster implementations that span as
many nodes as you want the the active
team once spun up a 3400 at cluster I
think it the cluster formed after about
5 minutes it's amazingly it's an amazing
thing amazingly powerful way to model
complex systems if you have that need so
basically if you want to do any kind of
CEP and you have and you've already
modeled you know all the rules that all
the type of derivative functions you
want to happen to this message as a
guest process through a complex EDP loop
then you can easily link to those actor
systems using active streams by just
using what's called the ask pattern and
I probably won't have time to get into
that today
but I encourage you to check it out and
then complex graphs so spark blink
Kefka streams as far as I know they're
all they only support a cyclic graphs
active streams actually allows you to
implement cycles within your graph if
you had that need not many people have
that need but it's definitely pretty
pretty interesting if you do have that
need then you can model it very easily
without having to you know basically
model it at a higher level through
different capture topics and things like
that so what I mean by a cycle is just a
loop within your pipeline so instead of
just kind of a linear downstream
pipeline you can have maybe a downstream
flow sending messages to an upstream
flow for for whatever reason to
influence that information somehow has
that's flowing through it so here's some
code not very interesting this is just
the ceremony to get the clients up up
and running so if you've worked with
calculus should kind of look familiar
this is Scalla code by the way and yeah
so you can use a you can use typesafe
config and have your your default client
that are consumer producer config in
there and then some other alpaca Kafka
config you set all the settings this way
and then here's a more interesting
example of an actual kind of end-to-end
workflow of a very simple access stream
and these are so that this committable
source and available sync here are
components of the alpaca kapha connector
so this is basically what you're
referencing and you're passing in your
connection details your
subscription and this particular source
is using it basically helping you model
at least one semantics by including
offset information for messages that
you're consuming downstream so that they
can eventually be committed
automatically on your behalf so you'll
have to do it for you so you'll have to
do it yourself rather so you all your
business logic would be in some form of
transformations here like a map or and
lots of other transformations that are
available with akka streams yeah and
then yeah the like I said once the
acknowledgement comes back that this
thing has been committed to her produced
to a topic then it will automatically
commit you know every single message or
a batch depending on how you want to
model those those semantics so normally
in this presentation I jump into
consumer groups and talked about
managing at least one semantics in more
detail but I didn't have a lot of time
so I chose one particular feature of
transactional sorry of alpaca Kafka and
that I thought you guys might find
interesting
so I've had two Kafka supports
transactions as of 0:11 I came out June
28th last year so transactions enable
atomic rights to multiple casket topics
and partitions all of the messages
included in transaction will
successfully be written or none of them
will be so that should sound pretty
familiar it's very similar to just any
old transaction with with a database
these semantics weren't possible before
zero 11 because a lot of features had
had to be added to the brokers and to
the clients to make it work so before
then these types of semantics weren't
possible you could you could try and
model them on top of
of Kafka but there were certain corner
cases that weren't supported where
you'll you'll always get it there is
always a possibility that messages can
be out of order I won't get into the
details but that but basically it's
related to how retries work within
within Kafka so this solves that
so before we we get into the guts of
transactions Kafka talks about three
message delivery semantics a support so
at most once is the most performant one
basically we're sending messages it's
fire-and-forget a good example is a game
client and server where you don't you
don't care about every message being
delivered you you only care about the
latest message so it's using the UDP
protocol and which which has you know it
doesn't have all this acknowledgment
stuff built into it and sending using at
most once message semantics are
basically the same thing models with
with Kafka we're just sending it and
you're not waiting for acknowledgments
before you send the next one at least
once is what most people want to use and
it's basically sending a message waiting
for an acknowledgment if the
acknowledgement doesn't come back then
we retry sending that message so there's
a possibility that we can send that
message more than once and downstream we
need to either just just accept that
fact or handle deduplication in some way
so that can be a pain and exactly once
is the holy grail of message delivery
semantics and I have it in quotes here
because exactly once message delivery if
you want to get really technical is not
possible so how does how does kapha
claim that they have exactly once
so let me let me explain that a little
more so there's a famous problem known
as the two generals / Byzantine generals
problem that says exactly ones message
delivery is impossible between two
parties where failures of communication
are possible so that seems fairly
definitive but what what we're actually
doing with chapter isn't violating this
rule because we're doing some other
things at a higher level so in in a IT
networking class you know you might be
learning about TCP you learn about
things like it most wants with regards
to like UDP protocol and at least once
with regards to TCP and then you know it
might talk about this how at that low
level you can't guarantee that the
message is only processed once sort of
received once processed once sent once
and lives once in the destination you
just can't make that guarantee at a very
low level you need a higher level of
abstraction and a more application kind
of specific point of view to make that
kind of thing in reality so that that's
the key basically we so exactly once
message delivery at a low level is
impossible but exactly once processing
at a higher level using a bunch of
tricks or faking a lot of the things to
make exactly once delivery look like as
possible is possible so some of the
things we're faking are retries until we
get an acknowledgment from the sink so
that's very similar to at least one
semantics so will will retry if message
isn't acknowledgment isn't sent back to
the client we have item potent data
sources so when the message ends up in
its destination we have some sort of way
of determining that that message has
already been sent so some kind of
deduplication is happening or and and
the last thing is we can guarantee that
messages are not processed more than
once through a couple features that were
I'm gonna show you in a second here so
here's the basic breakdown of
transactions within Kafka so you have
five things I'm going to go over here
quickly so the transaction coordinator
is basically a sub process that runs in
one of the brokers and it's
communicating with a client and there's
one of these coordinators per
transactional workflow it has an
internal katka topic knowing that it's a
transaction log and this is where all
the metadata about the transactions
happening
sorry stored you have control messages
we'll talk about a bit more in a second
but these are basically caps at the end
of the topics that you're producing to
to signal downstream that hey anything
before these control messages was
successfully processed you have a
transactional ID so this is similar to a
consumer group ID if you're familiar
consumer group
it basically differentiates this program
from another transactional program and
and also fends off any duplicates of
that program that might try and trample
over the messages that you're processing
so if you have Brittany Sam example two
programs running with the same ID cafe
will guarantee that only one of them can
actually commit a transaction at a time
so they can't both commit transactions
at the same time because then obviously
you'd lose a lot of the guarantees that
exactly once is trying to give you and
the way that transit and the way that
works is by there's a there's a
generation the version number for every
session of a transaction that's appended
to the transactional ID it's just called
an epoch number it's just a increasing
number it gets appended so if another
transactional application tries to join
it's going to they call it fencing off
it's going to fence off the older
generation of that program and say
you know roll back your transaction a
new a new player has entered the game
and your any data you you have in your
transaction that's not committed is null
and void and then the new application
will resume from the latest committed
offsets that were sorry it'll consume
from the lay that last committed offsets
so the the three features that enable
transactions and kapha are the are
idempotent producers multiple partition
Tomic rights and consumer read isolation
level so i producers are really easy to
explain this is all all the
transactional semantics on the client
from the client perspective are built
into the the kappa / doucer api so you
have a client here it's join the cluster
it has a producer ID this is a ID that
gets generated by by your cluster for
you and it's kind of like a session
identifier and then you have this
sequence number that's one to one for
every partition that you're producing to
so for each position you have a sequence
number so you're sending your first
message here you're starting from 0 this
producer ID the broker receives it and
persisted into a partition along with
that metadata and now the broker is
expecting the next message which would
be which would have a sequence of 1 for
this particular petition but what if
something happens where the broker is
trying to acknowledge that this message
was persisted and that doesn't go
through the client is going to retry and
it it's gonna send the exact same
information again but instead of failing
the broker can simply say oh that's ok
it's still a successful request that you
made but you can stop worrying about
trying to resend that message I already
have it so it signals that there's a
duplicate already if it sent a sequence
number if there was like a gap in the
sequence number like it tried to send to
before received 1 that would be a fail
exception for the transaction everything
would be rolled back so this is this is
the idempotent producer and multiple
partition atomic rights are required to
make sure that the commit process
guarantees all the information all the
messages that are in the transaction all
the messages that we consumed from our
source topic have been read make sure
all these things happen kind of in one
one operation so this is this is
basically a it's a it's a two-phase
commit so the the first activity that
happens when you commit the transaction
is that it will update the transaction
log with a message saying we're
preparing to commit the transaction
it'll and and then once once that's been
acknowledged that that is in the
transaction log then we can add these
control messages to all the topics we're
producing - and we can also commit that
all the messages we consumed have been
read and we do this all at once and all
or nothing operation if any one of these
things fails and obviously the whole
transaction isn't valid anymore so it
needs to be rolled back it went once
they all happen successfully then the
transaction is committed and everything
is is good to go and finally the read
isolation level is for downstream
consumers of your your transactional
work flow so we described a simple
consume transform produce by consuming
from Kafka producing to Kafka I forgot
to mention that before it has to be the
same traffic cluster and it has to be
consuming from Kafka and producing back
to Kafka - to get these guarantees so
assuming that the transaction was
successfully committed then any maybe
you have another transactional program
downstream that's reading consuming from
the
partitions you are producing two right
it looks for if it has this setting of
isolation read committed then it it
knows to wait for this control message
to show up before it starts consuming
messages because it only wants to
consume messages or we're part of a
successful transaction so the the
opposite setting for this if it's not
defined is read uncommitted and that's
basically the old you know standard way
of consuming from Khafre which is
basically as fast as possible depending
on some other plying consistency
guarantees you can tune in client config
but but yeah that's that's how that
works
so transactional workflows are actually
very fast and the in the design papers
that Kafka created it when they
implemented some of these semantics they
they did a comparison where they picked
a good they picked a good interval to
commit transactions like a at a certain
at a certain level of batching of
messages in a transaction the the
overhead of a transaction was negligible
over time the performance penalty that
you do pay though is is end-to-end
latency within your app and within your
overall pipeline so if each one of these
is a transactional application they'll
commit based on some sort of interval
whether it's based on time or message or
number of messages usually it's time and
say it is time then the latency you're
gonna see at the end of this pipeline is
going to be an aggregate of all the
latency of these transactional commits
because it has to commit a whole batch
before the next one can consume them so
this is what you got to watch out for
when when using this in a longer and a
longer pipeline so here's how alpaca
Kafka implements this it's very similar
to the way CAFTA streams does it itself
there's basically a
a loop happening right here where the
every 100 milliseconds by default which
is the same as catfish dreams it will
try to commit all these messages so what
it does as messages enter the
transactional sink or this can be
modeled as a flow as well
the messages are added to the
transaction produced and then we have a
little bucket here waiting for the
acknowledgments for every messages
message we're consuming and then when it
comes time to commit once this this
interval elapses we we commit the
transaction and we have to we have to do
a couple things in order to make sure
that that works properly and I'm going
to go through a short workflow here how
that works so the graph stage this is an
example of the transactional graph stage
it has a transactional status it has a
backpressure status is it exhibiting
back pressure is it not and it has this
commit loop which is basically signaling
when the transaction should be committed
then it has a transaction with the
actual messages and that that bucket I
mentioned earlier so this is the
transaction in progress the transactions
are then begun in the last slide it's
open now it's receiving messages they're
coming into the mailbox they're being
committed to Khafre and these are some
of the outstanding ones we're waiting
for responses to and then this this
commit loop elapses and the way that
this the way that we signal to this
transactional graph stage like when to
stop receiving more messages is by
sending another message to ourselves
this is kind of a neat way of modeling
concurrency within an act one actor
instead of actually closing over some
code and mutating state which creates
all those kind of race conditions and
hard concurrency problems we were
probably familiar with we simply send an
internal message to our mailbox saying
this is the message that will actually
start the transaction any messages after
this transaction will not be part of the
sorry part after this message will not
be part of the transaction in fact this
message itself when it's processed by
this stage actually suspends the
backpressure so no more messages can
actually enter the mailbox so at this
stage we're okay where we're draining
the messages we waited for all the
acknowledgments they come back and we
commit the transaction using that that
that two-phase commit and then we begin
a new transaction so here's the code
it's very similar to what I showed
before it's just a source transfer
transformation and and commit so yes I
was very complicated what I just
described all the transactional
implementations but for the end user the
good news is it's really simple and easy
to use the only difference here really
is that we have a transactional idea
we're using different source and sinks
so I don't have time to go into all this
but this is alpaca Kafka was just
released 1.0 milestone 1 on November 6 a
couple days ago it has a new team at
light Bend that's kind of rebooted it
it's got a lot of community interest now
there's a lot of new features in it so I
hope that you guys might find it of
interest so akka is basically a toolkit
it's not a framework you pick and choose
what you want to use and build your own
streaming platforms or micro services or
whatever you want with it and I'll pack
a copy it's just one component of that
so hopefully I've given you some ideas
on what you can build and and and yeah
Thanks so that's it
you
[Music]